antes se pensaba que todos los ciclos
arcanos eran planos se creía que el
ciclo propano era un triángulo plano que
el ciclo botta no era un cuadrado plano
que el ciclo penta no era un pentágono
plano y que el ciclo hexano era un
hexágono plano pero vamos a analizar
todos estos tomando en cuenta la tensión
angular la atención angular es el
aumento de energía asociado con el
ángulo de un enlace que se desvía del
ángulo ideal de ciento 9.5 grados quizá
este número le suene familiar porque
anteriormente hablamos de ese ángulo en
la geometría te trae drica pero si
analizamos este compuesto aquí tenemos
un ángulo de 60 grados que está muy
lejos de los 109.5 eso significa que el
ciclo propano tiene una tensión angular
importante
para el ciclo butano este ángulo es de
90 grados que aún está muy lejos de
109.5 así que el ciclo butano también
tiene una tensión angular importante
para el ciclo pentano este ángulo es de
108 grados es muy cercano a ciento 9.5 y
para el ciclo hexano aquí tenemos un
ángulo de 120 grados entonces podríamos
pensar que el ciclo penta no es el más
estable porque tiene el ángulo más
cercano al ángulo ideal de ciento 9.5
grados sin embargo eso no coincide si
analizamos los calores de combustión
primero tenemos al ciclo propano que
tiene un calor de combustión un cambio
negativo de entalpía de 2.091 kilo jules
por cada molde ciclo propano quemado y
si contamos el número de grupos
todos observen que tenemos 1 2 y 3 por
eso tenemos un 3 aquí si analizamos los
ciclo alcanos comparando sus calores de
combustión observen que va aumentando de
2.091 a 2 mil 721 a 3 mil 291 y a 3.920
lo cual era de esperarse porque al pasar
de ciclo propano a ciclo butano ventana
y hexano estamos aumentando los carbonos
y por el vídeo anterior sabemos que al
aumentar el número de carbonos aumenta
el calor de combustión así que no
podemos comparar los ciclo alcanos
únicamente con los calores de combustión
necesitamos compararlos con el calor de
combustión dividido entre el número de
grupos de h2 eso nos dará una mejor idea
de la estabilidad entonces si el calor
de combustión es de 2.091
el ciclo propano y lo dividimos entre
los grupos ch2 que son 3 obtenemos un
valor de aproximadamente 600 97 este es
el calor de combustión dividido entre el
número de grupos
ch todos en kilo jules por mol y esta es
una mejor forma de comparar la
estabilidad de ciclo alcanos observen
que el ciclo propano tiene el valor más
alto 697 el ciclo butano baja a 680 el
ciclo venta no baja a 658 y el ciclo
hexano baja a 653 si ve en el vídeo
anterior de calores de combustión este
valor de 653 es muy cercano a la
diferencia entre los calores de
combustión de los arcanos por cada grupo
de h2 que agrega vamos el calor de
combustión aumentaba aproximadamente 605
y 4 kilos por mol y eso significa que el
ciclo hexano casi no tiene tensión es
muy estable sin embargo el ciclo hexano
no es plano y lo veremos en los
siguientes vídeos entonces el ciclo
hexano es el más estable de todos estos
ciclo alcanos el ciclo penta no es un
poco más alto en energía y por lo tanto
es un poco más inestable después tenemos
al ciclo butano que es más inestable y
finalmente el ciclo propano con un valor
de 697 como resultado del calor de
combustión entre el número de grupos sea
chetos es el más inestable tiene el
valor más alto analicemos por qué el
ciclo propano tiene un valor tan alto de
calor de combustión por grupo ch2 aquí
tenemos el modelo molecular del ciclo
propano si lo volteó podemos ver que los
tres carbonos c
en el mismo plano pero observen la
tensión angular que hay en estos enlaces
eso significa que los orbitales no se
traslapan muy bien incluso los enlaces
plásticos se doblan un poco y podemos
ver otra fuente de tensión si observamos
uno de los enlaces carbono-carbono aquí
los hidrógenos frontales estan
eclipsados con los hidrógenos de atrás y
el ciclo propano está atrapado en esta
conformación eclipsado si hay mucha
tensión eso significa que el anillo es
muy reactivo sobre todo en reacciones de
apertura
entonces si rompemos el anillo observen
que disminuye la tensión los enlaces ya
no están forzados
aquí tenemos la molécula de ciclo butano
observen que hay un poco de tensión en
estos enlaces si lo volteamos podemos
ver que los hidrógenos frontales están
eclipsados con los hidrógenos de atrás y
para liberar esa tensión el ciclo butano
puede adoptar una conformación diferente
que se conoce como la conformación de
mariposa si lo giramos para ver un
enlace carbono carbono observen que se
ha liberado la atención los hidrógenos
frontales ya no estan eclipsados con los
de atrás finalmente tenemos la molécula
de ciclo pentano que tiene menos tensión
que el ciclo propano o el ciclo butano
pero si lo giramos podemos ver que
tenemos algunos hidrógenos eclipsados un
poco de esa tensión puede ser liberada
al cambiar a una conformación distinta
moviendo este carbono se conoce como la
conformación de sobre observen que 4
carbonos se encuentran en el mismo plano
estos 4 carbonos están en el mismo plano
pero el quinto se encuentra arriba del
plano y por eso se le llama conformación
de sobre ahora que entendimos la
estabilidad de los ciclo 'la acá nos
hagamos rápidamente un problema del lado
izquierdo tenemos a led y el ciclo
propano y del lado derecho tenemos al
medir ciclo butano estos dos son mis o
meros y tienen una fórmula molecular de
5 h 10 la primera pregunta es que y
somero es más estable bueno si
comparamos un anillo de tres miembros
con uno de cuatro miembros
sabemos que el ciclo propano tiene más
energía hay más tensión así que el x
ciclo propano es el y somero menos
estable
menos estable
lo que significa que el metil ciclo
butano es más estable
este es el y somero más estable así que
hay menos tensión en el metil ciclo
butano entonces hemos resuelto la
primera pregunta y la segunda pregunta
dice cuál tiene el calor de combustión
más alto bueno sabemos que el compuesto
más estable tiene el calor de combustión
más bajo es decir que el metil ciclo
butano tiene menor calor de combustión
porque es más estable y eso significa
que el epp y el ciclo propano debe tener
mayor calor de combustión a mayor calor
de combustión es menos estable